[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abends am flughafen von kabul ist
eine beruhigung der lage nicht in sicht
am vierten tag in folge spielten sich
dort erschütternde szenen ab der
deutsche brigadegeneral art der den
evakuierungseinsatz leitet berichtete
heute online von der dramatischen lage
während im hintergrund schüsse zu hören
waren hier sehen wir ein video der
agentur pti wie vielerorts kräfte unter
den chaotischen bedingungen tatsächlich
noch ausgeflogen werden können ist
völlig unklar doch die zeit drängt denn
nach einem un-bericht suchen die taliban
inzwischen intensiv nach helfern der
westlichen truppen ein
familienangehöriger eines journalisten
der deutschen welle wurde nach auskunft
des senders getötet liepert
geschäftiges treiben in der innenstadt
von kabul heute der alltag ist zurück
scheinbar doch schwer bewaffnete
radikale islamisten haben jetzt das
sagen und sie lassen die menschen spüren
wie die neue zeit aussehen wird im netz
kursieren bilder von hausdurchsuchungen
in kabul jagdszenen auf jene die für ein
anderes ein freies afghanistan stehen
wie die fernsehmoderatorin schapmann
daran heute früh ließen die neuen
machthaber sie nicht mehr ins
fernsehgebäude sie sollen nach hause so
die drohung
ich appelliere an die internationale
staatengemeinschaft mein leben ist in
gefahr bitte helfen sie mir
mutige frauen trugen heute zum
unabhängigkeitstag mit dutzenden
weiteren demonstranten die
nationalflagge in den straßen der stadt
offener widerstand gegen die taliban
wir lassen uns nicht mehr knechte wir
knie nicht vor euch nieder sagen sie
das ist unser land und wir werden es mit
allen mitteln verteidigen
andere sehen keine zukunft mehr für sich
und ihre familie tausende strömten heute
trotz des gefährlichen chaos weiter zum
flughafen in der hoffnung doch irgendwie
durchzukommen die taliban kontrollieren
jeden auch menschen die schon vor wochen
vor den islamisten geflohen waren wie
eine ärztin aus herat
die wollen frauen mit ihren kämpfern
zwangsverheiraten ich bin ärztin meine
schwester frauenrechtsaktivistin wir
sind in gefahr
am flughafen tor dann nach all dem
risiko die quälende ungewissheit sind
die richtigen papiere vorhanden und
gelingt es den richtigen soldaten
diplomaten oder ansprechpartner zu
finden der das tor dann öffnet den
anderen bleibt nur das bittere gefühl im
stich gelassen zu werden den rettenden
flug nicht mehr erreichen zu können
1280 menschen wurden über die luftbrücke
inzwischen nach deutschland gebracht und
doch die bundeskanzlerin sprach heute
von einem so wörtlich international
koordinierten einsatz
der bundesinnenminister beteuerte alle
zitat alle ortskräfte nach deutschland
holen zu wollen da war die diskrepanz
zwischen der gerade gesehenen
wirklichkeit in kabul und den worten in
berlin doch groß die fehlersuche und die
nach verantwortlichen für das versagen
in afghanistan ging in der hauptstadt
berlin heute weiter im fokus dabei unter
anderem der auslandsgeheimdienst bnd
klaus brodbeck berichtet es wird geheim
behandelt was nicht geheim bleiben darf
das parlamentarische kontrollgremium und
die frage wie konnte der bnd die lage in
afghanistan
derart falsch einschätzen wo er sich
dort doch stets besonders guter
kenntnisse rühmte die zuständigen
behörden haben uns deutlich gemacht dass
nach ihren erkenntnissen die entwicklung
vom wochenende in kabul und afghanistan
nicht absehbar waren doch auch die wie
der dienst mit informationen versorgt
haben möglicherweise versorgt mein
eindruck war dass
die dienste geliefert haben und wir ein
problem haben
bei der bewertung und der gesamtbild
erstellung auf seiten der
bundesregierung das chaos das keiner
vorhersehen wollte haben sie mit glück
hinter sich frankfurt heute abend
ankunft 72 stunden nach ihrer flucht
der deutsche hat uns geholfen wir haben
also bisher gekommen sind alle leute
sehr angst die leute will einfach raus
gehen schon auf ganz hand
sorgen männer frauen kinder ältere halle
seit tagen in der kritik horst seehofer
im innenausschuss konfrontiert mit dem
vorwurf die visavergabe in afghanischer
ortskräfte verschleppt zu haben
er hat darauf bestanden über wochen dass
die ob die ortskräfte erst dort gecheckt
werden dass man sicherheitsüberprüfung
macht das visa erteilt werden in
afghanistan anstatt die zeit zu nutzen
die menschen rechtzeitig aus afghanistan
nach deutschland zu bringen stimmt nicht
wird sich seehofer heute das gegenteil
sei der fall und das schon seit mai
ich sage wir haben zu einem frühen
zeitpunkt
klar gemacht dass an uns dem
innenministerium bäder ein charter flug
scheitert
noch
die visaerteilung in deutschland und die
sicherheitsüberprüfung in deutschland
das scheitern des westens in afghanistan
dürfen sich nun im umgang mit
flüchtlingen aus afghanistan nicht
wiederholen selbst wenn tausende kämen
müsse deutschland sich um sie kümmern
seehofer kommt damit forderungen von
kirchenvertretern entgegen
die genfer flüchtlingskonvention und
dass die grundrechte das so recht
asylrecht darf nicht außer kraft gesetzt
werden im gegenteil deutschland sollte
sich vorbereiten im rahmen der
möglichkeiten die das deutschland hat
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen völlig offen
noch heute wie lange noch kann
deutschland denen helfen die für
deutsche stellen in afghanistan
gearbeitet haben die situation des
nichtstuns hat uns jetzt in einer
situation gebracht dass wir ab rest sind
ablesbar oder erpresst werden können
mit menschenleben das was jetzt passiert
ich denke es bedauern alle beteiligten
gleichermaßen
hätte natürlich früher passieren sollen
menschen zu retten versagen aufzuklären
sich selbst zu erklären der druck steigt
die zeit wird knapp
vorsitzende des innenausschusses und
mitglied im parlamentarischen
kontrollgremium ist die csu abgeordnete
andrea lindholz die somit heute einen
intensiven arbeitstag hatte und gerade
aus berlin zurückkommt wie erreichen sie
am frankfurter flughafen im freiland
holz
guten abend erschossen so also die
befragung des innenministers befragung
des chefs des auslandsgeheimdienstes bnd
was haben sie jetzt heute für
erkenntnisse gewonnen wie es zu dieser
völligen fehleinschätzung der lage in
afghanistan kommen konnte
also wir haben heute keine abschließende
antwort darauf bekommen wie es zu der
fehleinschätzung kommen konnte es ist
ganz einfach so dass der schnelle
rückzug der truppen in afghanistan
selbst die aufgabe und die übernahme
durch die taliban dass die weder von
deutschen sicherheitsbehörden noch von
denen anderer länder ausreichend früh
erkannt worden ist und deswegen ist es
jetzt auch das wichtigste das wir
schauen dass wir so viele menschen wie
nur irgendwie möglich deutsche aber auch
natürlich orts helfer aus afghanistan
heraus bringen können auch das heute
thema bei uns im ausschuss und ich will
auch ganz klar sagen es sind noch nicht
alle fragen beantwortet worden und wir
werden auch die aufklärung weiter
betreiben der punkt ist aber jetzt
erstmal dass wir uns jetzt wirklich
dringend um die rettung der menschen
kümmern müssen und das ist auch im gang
um rettung zuerst sagen sie gleichwohl
forschen sie ja nach was ist eigentlich
passiert und man hat ja den eindruck so
eines kollektiven versagens von
geheimdiensten und politik gleichermaßen
sie selber schließen ja auch einen
untersuchungsausschuss nicht aus ist er
nötig
das kann man zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nichts sagen auch die ausschüsse haben
eine gute möglichkeit um die dinge
hinterher aufzuklären und genau zu
analysieren ob es dann dazu unbedingten
aus untersuchungsausschuss braucht das
will ich gar nicht bewerten heute aber
es ist vollkommen klar dass man mit der
situation überhaupt nicht zufrieden sein
kann und das wird nach den
rettungsmaßnahmen die jetzt absolut im
vordergrund stehen ganz genau
analysieren müssen an welcher stelle man
hätte man vielleicht anders reagieren
können was müssen wir da auch für die
zukunft für schlüsse draus ziehen es ist
nicht optimal gelaufen also muss es
aufgearbeitet werden manchmal ist aber
auch die aufarbeitung in ausschüssen
wesentlich ziehen in einem
untersuchungsausschuss aber das müssen
die parlamentarier dann entscheiden
jetzt geht das ist das retten der
menschen einfach vor und auch die
gruppen zu identifizieren um die es alle
geht aber viele sagen an dieser stelle
die viele hätten längst gerettet sein
können wenn man den innenminister heute
heute hört er sagt die moralische
verantwortung sei natürlich alle ports
kräfte nach deutschland zu holen dann
klingt das natürlich schon wie hohn weil
man hätte im juni längst damit in großem
stil beginnen können
also man hat einfach eine andere
einschätzung gehabt dann ist davon
ausgegangen der innenminister zeit ganz
deutlich gesagt an ihm hat es nicht
gelegen dass das man nicht in größerem
umfang menschen auch orts helfer eben
aus afghanistan raus geholt hat soll man
ist einfach davon ausgegangen dass das
zeitfenster ein größeres ist und es war
die ganze zeit schon möglich dass man
natürlich auch als im orts helfer wenn
eine bestimmte gefahrenlage vorlag
afghanistan verlassen konnte das haben
auch in den vergangenen jahren fast 5000
menschen gemacht die frage ist aber eine
ganz andere
die frage ist warum hat man es eben so
spät gesehen und hätte man nicht die
chance ergreifen müssen dann auf den
einen oder anderen vorher aktiv
zuzugehen und das ist halt einfach der
punkt dass man von einem zu langen
zeitfenster ausgegangen ist die sage es
ist eine schwierige lage sie sagen horst
seehofer hat es dargestellt schlüssig
dargestellt aus ihrer sicht sind sind
seine argumente denn heute überzeugend
gewesen denn es gab ja den antrag der
grünen es gab ja auch längst einen
beschluss im juni man hätte beginnen
können was ist denn die erklärung frisia
lindholm warum man eben nicht begonnen
hat nur weil man noch dachte man hat
noch zeit oder weiß im grunde politisch
motiviert weil man die botschaft nicht
ausgeben wollte wir höhe wir holen
afghanischer ortskräfte nach deutschland
also horst seehofer hat heute im
innenausschuss schon in den ausschuss
heute klar gemacht dass er and dass man
ende meister und darauf verzichtet hat
dass das innenministerium auch meine
zweite prüfung vornehmen bei der frage
ist jemand eine gefährdete person dass
er auch noch im juni gesagt hat wenn man
der auffassung ist dass man in größerem
stil auch mit charterflügen personen
ohne diese ohne prüfung des visums in
afghanistan sondern erst in deutschland
nach deutschland holen will dann ist das
innenministerium da absolut liegt es
keine steine in den weg so und man hat
sich aber in der bundesregierung eben in
den kreisen mit dem man auch darüber
beraten hat im juli noch in einer
situation befunden dass man der
auffassung war es geht noch auf dem
diesen anführungszeichen normalen weg
das heißt die orts helfer werden den
behörden von den behörden denen sie
zugeordnet werden die stehen mit ihnen
in kontakt und dann dann können die
anträge stellen das im prinzip das land
verlassen wollen und wenn die muss dann
auch zügig entschieden werden man ist
einfach von der anderen situation
ausgegangen dass sie das sagt die
kanzlerin das hat auch der außenminister
gesagt und das ist eine fehleinschätzung
gewesen das hat auch ihk der leiter
leiter des bundesnachrichtendienstes
gesagt und gute diesmal sollen alle
sagen auch wlan stationen auch
beteiligten alle sagen
fehleinschätzungen im ergebnis schieben
sich jetzt aber alle die verantwortung
gegenseitig zu und das werfen damit
natürlich auch ein stück weit
nebelkerzen wer muss am ende die
verantwortung übernehmen oder sind sie
auch der ansicht das lohnt sich gar
nicht mehr in ein paar wochen wird ja
gewählt dann haben wir ohnehin eine
andere bundesregierung
also ich finde der ganze sachverhalt
muss äußerst gründlich aufgearbeitet
werden frau schausten und möglicherweise
ist es am ende so das handelnde person
dass es gar nicht mehr um handelnde
person geht sondern es geht um die sache
wir stehen am ende dieser
legislaturperiode
ich wünsche mir zunächst mal das
möglichst vielen menschen geholfen
werden kann das mixed dass die
luftbrücke möglichst lange hält das es
noch gelingt möglichst viele menschen
aus afghanistan raus zu holen dass es
gelingt entsprechende verhandlungen zu
führen und auch den menschen die
ausreise zu ermöglichen die ausreisen
wollen das hat erste priorität und
danach kommt die aufarbeitung und es
kann da tatsächlich nicht sein wir haben
heute drei ausschüsse also gestern zwei
ausschüsse haben gestern getagt einer
heute so und man muss das ganze
irgendwann mal zusammenbinden und muss
sagen welche erkenntnisse hat man aus
allen drei bereichen inklusive
kanzleramt aus allen vier bereichen und
sind da möglicherweise versäumnisse
gewesen die man in zukunft besser machen
muss an einer aufklärung geht kein weg
vorbei in welcher form und wie das wären
wir dann entscheiden sagt andrea
lindholz die vorsitzende des
innenausschusses parlamentariern der csu
herzlichen dank das gespräch und hier
geht es weiter mit nachrichten gut aus
der bundesgerichtshof hat das urteil
gegen die nsu terroristin beate treppe
als mittäterin bestätigt damit bleibt es
bei der strafe zu der sie 2018
verurteilt worden war lebenslange haft
bei besonderer schwere der schuld auch
die urteile gegen zwei weitere ns
unterstützer wurden bestätigt als
mitglied des sogenannten
nationalsozialistischen untergrunds
hatte chappell von dem jahr 2010
rassistisch motivierte morde mitgeplant
und ihre komplizen gedeckt diese hatten
sich 2011 das leben genommen um der
drohenden festnahme zu entgehen
in trier hat unter hohen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen der prozess
gegen den mann begonnen der im
vergangenen dezember mit einem suv durch
die dortige fußgängerzone raste und
dabei gezielt passanten anfuhr die
staatsanwaltschaft wirft dem angeklagten
fünffachen mord versuchten mord in 18
fällen sowie gefährliche und schwere
körperverletzung in 14 fällen vor sein
motiv ist bisher unklar auch zum
prozessauftakt erklärte der 51 jährige
keine aussage machen zu wollen ob er
aufgrund einer psychose nur
eingeschränkt schuldfähig ist soll ein
gutachten klären
die quote der vollständig gegen korona
geimpften in deutschland hat sich auf
58,2 prozent der bevölkerung erhöht das
sind 48 4 millionen menschen in der
diskussion über eine auffrischimpfung im
herbst sieht der virologe christian
drosten eine notwendigkeit nur für
risikopatienten und ältere menschen
zunächst gehe es darum die impflücken
bei den über 60-jährigen zu schließen
das robert koch institut registrierte
8400 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
2762 mehr als vor einer woche 22
menschen starben an oder mit dem virus
die sieben tage incident steigt weiter
auf aktuell
44,2
die waldbrände in griechenland in
italien und südfrankreich dauern an
ebenso wie im us bundesstaat kalifornien
dort kämpfen mehr als 10.000
feuerwehrleute gegen neue waldbrände
nördlich von san francisco vernichteten
ein dutzend größere brände zahlreiche
häuser die behörden forderten tausende
einwohner auf sich in sicherheit zu
bringen
extreme trockenheit und starke winde
erschweren die löscharbeiten
östlich von sacramento ist ein
brandgebiet innerhalb eines tages um
fast das zehnfache angewachsen auf rund
260 quadratkilometer
ja die welt ist in diesen tagen der
eindruck drängt sich manchem auf voll
von katastrophen wegsehen schaut sie
leider nicht aus der welt
deshalb müssen wir schauen auf haiti
immer wieder haiti das so geschlagen ist
von vielen naturkatastrophen dem
schweren erdbeben von letzter woche
folgte ein tropensturm der das elend
noch mal verstärkt auf fast
2200 ist die zahl der toten inzwischen
gestiegen und hilfe kommt immer noch
erst schleppend an denn zu der
humanitären kommt die politische krise
im karibikstaat claudia bertz berichtet
es war ja vorher schon so schlimm das
erdbeben hat das leben endgültig zur
hölle gemacht hier wo es aussieht als
hätte die erde gerade erst gebebt und
nicht schon vor fünf tagen hier in
diesem dorf ist noch keine hilfe
angekommen sie versuchen irgendwie
weiter zu leben aber wie soll das gehen
trümmer außen innen
hierunter wurde ein 15-jähriger begraben
das sind seine bücher er hatte sie
gerade bekommen für das neue schuljahr
jetzt ist er nicht mehr da ich bin mir
sein hemd um das gibt mir kraft
[Musik]
es ist schwer die ländlichen gebiete zu
erreichen die zufahrtsstraßen sind
verschüttet müssen erst freigeräumt
werden außerdem haben bewaffnete banden
das sagen sie schießen auf fahrzeuge es
gibt jetzt eine art waffenruhe aber es
hat tage gedauert bis man hierdurch
kommt der neue regierungschef als
krisenmanager
beauftragte der regierung kommen jetzt
und werden sich die folgen der
katastrophe anschauen sie treffen sich
mit den opfern und überbringen ihnen die
zusicherung dass die regierung begonnen
hat und auch weiterhin alles tun wird
was möglich ist um ihnen zu helfen
doch hier nehmen sie das anders war
unter den plastikplanen aufdecken im
dreck wo es ein täglicher kampf ist ums
überleben
wenn sie hilfe schicken dann müssen wir
sie auch bekommen die sollen sie nicht
einfach behalten sie haben die menschen
verlassen wir haben keinen präsidenten
keine abgeordneten keine minister wir
sind verlassen wir warten auf gott nur
noch
doch die hilfe kommt tage nach dem beben
aber sie kommt die us-küstenwache fliegt
jetzt in einige entlegene bergdörfer wo
die helfer sehnlichst erwartet werden
vor allem die schwerverletzten sollen in
krankenhäuser in der hauptstadt gebracht
werden
die große internationale hilfsaktion ist
jetzt mit voller kraft angelaufen
alles ist diesmal besser organisiert als
früher alle ziehen an einem strang es
geht jetzt auch schnell aber es bleibt
einfach zu wenig es ist ein tropfen auf
den heißen stein
so räumen sie weiter wo immer dies geht
brocken für brocken um ihre orte wieder
bewohnbar zu machen um hunderte aus den
trümmern zu bergen die noch vermisst
werden
wenn sie den opfern des erdbebens helfen
wollen sie können beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe spenden die iban
lautet de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 das
stichwort zdf nothilfe haiti
weitere informationen finden sie unter
spenden zdf de oder im text auf seite 8
190 und jetzt noch einmal nachrichten
hier im grunde
die deutsche wirtschaft hat zunehmend
probleme wegen der lieferengpässe bei
rohstoffen und vorprodukten vor allem
der anhaltende mangel an halbleitern
oder mikrochips drosselt die produktion
vieler unternehmen bei mehreren
autobauern stehen schon bänder still
stefanie bareth wird da gerade der nach
corona konjunkturaufschwung ausgebremst
zumindest hat die aktuelle entwicklung
das potenzial den deutschen
konjunkturmotor empfindlich ins stottern
zu bringen ökonomen rechnen bis weit ins
nächste jahr mit einer herausfordernden
zeit für unternehmer es geht wirklich
quer durch die branchen und fast alle
sind betroffen das offenbart heute eine
umfrage des dihk unter 3000 firmen
danach kämpfen fast 90 prozent der
unternehmen mit höheren preisen gut 40
prozent waren aufgrund der
lieferengpässe nicht in der lage ihre
bestehenden aufträge abzuarbeiten und
mehr als die hälfte der deutschen
fahrzeugindustrie plant
produktionsstopps oder eine drosselung
der automobilsektor ist am stärksten
betroffen deshalb startet etwa vw die
fertigung nach der sommerpause nur mit
angezogener handbremse
auch bei audi geht es für 10.000
beschäftigte nach den werksferien direkt
in die kurzarbeit
selbst der weltgrößte hersteller toyota
kündigte heute an seine produktion um
satte 40 prozent zurückzufahren das hat
die finanzmärkte aufgeschreckt auto
aktien standen hier heute erneut
erheblich unter druck auch der dax büßte
am ende 200 punkte oder 1,3 prozent ein
knappes angebot führt zu höheren preisen
das spüren auch verbraucher längst und
beim auto zu bleiben gebrauchtwaren
wagen waren im juli so teuer wie nie
zuvor stephanie beckert vielen dank
nach dem spektakulären juwelendiebstahl
aus dem grünen gewölbe in dresden sind
nun alle tatverdächtigen gefasst in
berlin haben die polizei einen 23
jährigen fest der wie seine mutmaßlichen
komplizen aus einer arabisch stämmigen
großfamilie stammt ihnen wird schwerer
bandendiebstahl und brandstiftung
vorgeworfen im november 2009 10 sollen
sie aus der historischen schatzkammer in
dresden wertvolle schmuckstücke des
siebzehnten und achtzehnten jahrhunderts
erbeutet haben die gestohlenen juwelen
sind von kaum schätz barem wert von
ihnen fehlt weiterhin jede spur
im internationalen fußball gibt es einen
neuen wettbewerb die uefa europa
conference liegt in der nicht nur top
klubs zum zug kommen einziger deutscher
teilnehmer ist der erste fc union berlin
der am abend sein auftaktspiel zur
qualifikation für die gruppenphase klar
gewonnen hat 14 0 in finnland gegen den
dortigen pokalsieger coupé s
am kommenden dienstag beginnen in tokio
die paralympics heute ging eine große
delegation des deutschen
behindertensportverbandes auf die reise
und wurde in frankfurt am main von
bundespräsident steinmeier verabschiedet
134 deutsche paralympics athleten werden
an 18 der 22 sportarten teilnehmen
unabhängig von ihrer medaillen aus
wollte so der bundespräsident
sollten sie bereits in jetzt stolz sein
zu den besten sportlern der welt zu
gehören auch das heute journal wird
wieder allabendlich aus tokio berichten
und noch einmal afghanistan wo all die
die sich in den letzten jahren für
freiheit und demokratie eingesetzt haben
nun fürchten dass alles verloren ist
einer ist der regisseur amin der als
teenager afghanistan verließ und heute
in filmen das schicksal seines landes
beschreibt kabul city gewinnt ist ein
preisgekrönter dokumentarfilm gerade
soll in afghanistan sein erster vom zdf
co produzierte spielfilm gedreht werden
doch nun sind nicht nur der film sondern
der gesamte mitarbeiterstab in gefahr
christhard läpple
ein busfahrer träumt von den alten hits
der 60er sein assistent von einer
besseren zukunft
kabul statt im wind war der erste
dokumentarfilm des regisseurs amini die
fortsetzung als spielfilm sollte jetzt
gedreht werden doch das gesamte team ist
in lebensgefahr nur der regisseur ist in
sicherheit in den niederlanden
hier sind wie viele andere in
afghanistan in schock und furcht weil
die welt kennt die taliban
das schicksal afghanistans bewegt die
deutschen gestern abend großer andrang
in frankfurt als kurzfristig amin ist
beeindruckender film gezeigt wurde die
menschen sind aufgerüttelt
mein vater kommt aus dem land der ist
oder aufgewachsen und deswegen finde ich
natürlich super schade für die menschen
dann kommt schon seit jahrzehnten nicht
zur ruhe und ja das macht mich einfach
traurig ich finds halt gut wenn man auf
jeden fall den menschen ermöglicht die
dann halt jetzt dort bedroht sind dass
sie halt irgendwie schutz bekommen
schutz sucht das gesamte filmteam 105
mitarbeiter sind in akuter gefahr
kommunikation geht nur noch über wurz in
den letzten tagen hat das team
unterlagen vernichtet berichtet der
regisseur die letzte hoffnung einen
platz in einem redmond flugzeug last
exit kabul
damit haben wir nicht gerechnet dass ich
das so rapide verändert es war klar dass
wir dann nicht drehen können aber diese
rapide veränderung damit haben wir nicht
gerechnet
amini zeigt dass andere afghanistan ohne
attentate bomben und gewalt doch die
allgegenwärtige angst spiegelt sich in
den augen der kinder trotzdem wird
getanzt gelacht und gehofft
[Musik]
was möchtest du werden wenn du groß bist
ich würde gern ingenieur werden
wir haben drei jahre an dem
dokumentarfilm gearbeitet in dieser zeit
haben wir 15 verschiedene
selbstmordanschläge erlebt
kinder die kriegsspiele generationen die
nichts anderes erlebt haben regisseur
amin ii hat mit 13 jahren sein land
verlassen flea so weit du kannst sagte
seine mutter was hält er nun nach der
rückkehr der taliban vom westen von
demokratie und menschenrechten
können wir einfach akzeptieren dass
unser kollektiver wille verletzt und
ignoriert wird auf die schlimmste und
barbarische weise das ist die
entscheidende frage für uns
bei dieser internationalen produktion
geht es längst nicht mehr um ein spiel
sondern um leben und tod
die welt hat in afghanistan versagt
lasst uns handeln bevor es zu spät ist
sind
rosa amini gibt die hoffnung nicht auf
den spielfilm seines lebens von
busfahrer in kabul will er unbedingt
drehen doch zuerst muss sein team
gerettet werden
ja das thema der woche ist afghanistan
und bleibt es auch hier im zdf in einer
spezialausgabe hat maybrit illner gäste
bei sich versammelt unter anderem die
grüne kanzlerkandidatin berbalk direkt
nach dem wetter und
gerne hinweisen wollen wir auch auf das
wahlduell für und wider nach 23 uhr
diesmal mit katja kipping von der linken
und tino keller von der afd
interessantesten
sanchez und bis morgen guten hand
[Musik]
guten abend hoch familie bringt uns am
wochenende einen turbo sommer mit 36
stunden haltbarkeit aber dann kommt
schon ein gewittertief heran und das
zieht bis montagfrüh einmal von west
nach ost über deutschland hinweg es
bringt kräftige unwetter mit hagel
platzregen und sturmböen in dieser nacht
ist es erstmal häufig starker bewölkung
besonders in norddeutschland fällt auch
etwas regen und dabei sinken die
temperaturen hier im osten auf 15 grad
im westen wird es mit elf grad etwas
kühler und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee bei 19 bis 20 grad
sonst werden 20 bis 24 und an mittel und
oberrhein sogar 26 grad erreicht dazu
sehen sie morgen an der nordseeküste
häufiger mal die sonne in einem streifen
hier vom nördlichen brandenburg bis zum
emsland bleibt es meist bedeckt da fällt
immer wieder regen und am vormittag kann
es richtung polen oder auch richtung
tschechien durchaus nochmal für ein
gewitter reicht dicht das ist die wolken
morgen auch rund um den thüringer wald
und das erzgebirge aber von südwesten
wird es von stunde zu stunde sonniger
dass es eben das hoch fridolin und so
gibt es am samstag für ganz deutschland
einen wunderschönen sommertag vielleicht
morgens noch ein bisschen nebel oder
dunst die temperaturen steigen auf 19
bis 29 grad und dann kommt das
gewittertief hier von westen heran am
sonntag mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen sind diese unwetter zum teil
verbunden die neue woche startete
wechselhaft guten ab